just four hours before the deadline to
request a parliamentary immunity from
prosecution expired the Israeli Prime
Minister appeared on television and said
he would ask the Knesset the Israeli
Parliament to grant him immunity the
hability observed Amish but it's my
intention to stand before the call to
shatter all the fabricated accusations
against me they're citizens of Israel
the immunity law is meant to protect
elected officials from tailored law
suits from serving political cases who
aim to harm the will of the people he
has filed a request with the Speaker of
the Knesset but it's likely to be months
before MPs vote on it Israel will hold
its third election in a year in March
Netanyahu's request can only be debated
by a parliamentary committee once a
government has been formed it then has
to come out of committee and be
presented to Knesset members to be voted
on forming a government could take
months
however some politicians are pushing to
speed up the process holding the
committee stage before the election
already the request for immunity has
divided Israeli politicians avek d'Or
Lieberman from the Israeli home party
and an influential figure has said he
won't vote for mmunity Netanyahu's only
good party has said it will vote for
immunity in November Israelis Attorney
General decided to indict Prime Minister
Netanyahu in three separate criminal
cases that alleged fraud bribery and
breach of trust
I made the decision to issue an
indictment against him with a heavy
heart a heavy heart perhaps but
wholeheartedly
with a deep sense of commitment to the
rule of law to the public's interest and
to the citizens of the State of Israel
Netanyahu and his supporters have
claimed that the charges are politically
motivated and that law enforcement and
the judicial system are in effect
mounting a coup against him Netanyahu
now faces a tough political fight yes to
win an election form a government and
then persuade MPs to vote for immunity
immunity only lasts as long as he is in
office as Prime Minister or if he
remains a member of
knesset the move will delay the
prosecution of these three court cases
by months or even stall the process
completely until Netanyahu is out of
politics it's already been a very
uncertain year in Israeli politics and
the future it would seem is equally
uncertain Imran Khan al Jazeera West
Jerusalem